cool let's get started so we're Andrew
and PRI Rose and we're the organizers of
fractal fractal is a walkable campus
full of friendly ambitious nerds in New
York City and it's an example of how you
can physically gather your online
network over just a couple years we're
still early but we want to share our
story as a case study for those of you
who out there dream like us of one day
settling down surrounded by a dense
network of friends who inspire
you but of course like all interesting
projects fractal is iterative organizing
fractal was an iterative process and
we'll walk you through our cycle so that
you can get a feel for it yourself
starting of course with a
vision isolated by typical working life
and a pandemic we dreamt up maybe a
somewhat typical utopic vision of
raising kids in a multigenerational
village of the future uh we would blend
technology urbanism and networked
Community to create a new kind of Life
uh we would be economically power
powerful and Sovereign but it would be
built by and for our friends not
faceless Industries we would Mentor each
other's kids we'd create a solarpunk
library a coffee shop a cafe we would
start companies and friendly rivalries
we'd build a university we'd dance we'
sing
together but we're not delusional people
have been dreaming about fairy tale
Utopias for generations and Utopia
doesn't exist like that in reality you
can't just create a new Society whole
cloth you have to inherit and build on
one
that you were given we believe there's
no secret sauce no magical government
structure no economic system that solves
all our problems Community organizers
have to incrementally slouch toward
Utopia like everybody else that being
said you should still write your
Manifesto but I'm getting ahead of
myself after we decided to take the
project seriously and enter execution
stage we did three things we wrote Our
Manifesto we started a research project
and most importantly we started our
first project in New York City and we
had to do that to learn everything that
books couldn't teach us so it's been
about two years since then and while we
don't have our solar Punk Utopia yet we
do have a campus of 36 residents that
serves as a shelling point for over 400
people we have a third space where we
co-work and we host events we teach
classes we run a Civic boot camp where
you learn all about the history and
governance of New York City and we run
art residencies so what does a typical
week at fractal look like let me show
you a movie night
uh a silent reading and writing night a
machine learning class a demo day for a
community building class a music
jam a trash pickup and lots and lots of
spontaneous
Hangouts so how did we go from nomadic
to network Village in two years well was
pretty simple we had three key
ingredients and these ingredients help
solve the cold start problem so once the
neighborhood is successful then it
becomes self-propagating but how do you
get a neighborhood begun in the first
place that is the cold start problem so
the first thing we did is we planted the
flag so essentially our friends needed
to believe that we were committed to
being in a particular place before they
uprooted their own lives to come live
with us so essentially we chose a
neighborhood in East Williamsburg in
Brooklyn New York and we wrote up our
vision and then we posted it online and
we sent it to our
friends then we started hosting weekly
so that our community could come
together so we essentially we just host
a dinner party every Sunday night and
our friends knew that they were always
default invited and that they could
bring a plus one and so in that way our
Network started to grow and to densify
and become a
community and we also offered short-term
stays so many of our friends had this
paradu of choice they essentially had
remote jobs and they could live in any
City that they wanted and so post
pandemic they were living nomadically
but they knew that they wanted to settle
down somewhere they just didn't know
where so we give our chance we give a
chance to our friends to stay with us
for a couple of days or a couple of
months before they sign a lease in our
building so what can you learn from our
story if you want to build a campus with
your friends first of all we recommend
that you keep it simple when we first
had this idea of living in a
neighborhood with our friends we were
told oh my friends and I have been
dreaming about doing that for years but
there was this consistent feeling when
they said that that the talk was just
talk and that coordinating friends and
timelines is impossibly complex but we
don't think so we think the reason is
because people have bloated plans they
have these massive Pie in the Sky
visions and they try to execute on it
all at once and they aren't willing to
accept a piece meal or shallow version
of it our friends would say first I'm
going to get rich and then I'm going to
get land and then I'll get 20 of my
friends and family to all agree on where
to live and then I'll build a village
but we weren't Rich we didn't put any
money in fractal Beyond paying the rent
on our own apartment friends who wanted
to move near us simply sign their own
lease in our building and we think
because of this that building a
neighborhood is a coordination problem
not a money problem to reiterate we
didn't need money or land or Dows or
software or governance to build our
neighborhood and neither do you that's
not to knock any of these things though
they are important Technologies and they
should be used when appropriate but when
appropriate is not when you're alone in
your apartment dreaming of a community
we believe that you should add these
things on top of a community that has
already shown its ability to coordinate
and trust each other in other words
Network first then state so remember
incrementalism
wins everybody wants to be Lady Gaga
performing at the Super Bowl but it's
easy to want something So Glamorous the
truth is Lady B Gaga had to play at
small parking lot concerts for years
before she became that famous similarly
the very beginning of a network Village
isn't that glamorous it's not that sexy
it's sexy maybe 10 or 20 years down the
line hopefully
so you when we first moved into our
apartment building it was just three of
us three of us with a dream and you have
to enjoy being three people starting to
build this in the same way that Lady
Gaga enjoyed playing concert Park
playing concerts in parking
lots so perhaps we should be up here
trying to convince you why our project
is special and irreplaceable and why we
are such important and valuable Founders
but I hope to do the opposite I want you
to walk away thinking that doesn't sound
so hard
maybe I should be up there I want you to
go home and host your first weekly event
I want you to go home and plant the flag
that you know you should be planting and
share an imperfect but obviously better
vision of what life could be with your
friends and if you don't know who to
send that Vision to send it to me I love
reading that stuff as for us when we get
home we have New Visions to execute on
and we could use your
help so first we're going
multigenerational that means researching
and experimenting on homeschools
Community Nursery and Library design
designs technology for babies child care
temporary baby apprenticeships for our
baby curious friends we're also building
a network University uh world class
knowledge is already free which is
something I find quite interesting and
we basically believe that network of
friends will take advantage of this
first by offering cheap courses to each
other and to the public our mission is
to be some of the first people to do
this to prove the model works and then
open source it so that people like you
people like us can build it all over the
place finally we're planning a rural
village within driving distance from our
current Community this one's obvious
enough we want a retreat center to
escape the city when things get kind of
crazy and a place for parents to build a
life that's a little bit slower maybe
eventually a proper campus for the
university project if you find yourself
excited about any of these please reach
out to us we could use all the help we
can get that being said we're all going
to make it thank you very much enjoy the
network State
Conference